the biggest problem here is 81 in
savings that's eight thousand dollars to
charity that I think this kid just cost
me
[Music]
September 9th 2023 trash talk is back I
was at the uh sports car National back
in uh July I probably had 40 50 people
mentioned your garage sale videos are my
favorite you're watching your videos
for free I watch your like garage videos
so dusting off some of the cobwebs we
should have a good day today I'm pretty
excited about it uh going to Springfield
New Jersey the old stomping grounds
literally home of the iconic Wine
Library let me get this disclaimer out
of the way I am not someone who's earned
his professional career going around and
trying to rip off people from five
dollars to two dollars I see the
comments out of context uh in Social
usually when it's a small clip out of
tick tock where I'm showing something
people are like this [__] millionaire
was ripping up so here's what we're
gonna do all money saved right when I
negotiate because this show is to show
people how to start when they are at a
very low Financial point so I'm going to
go walk in right now and see a stuffed
animal and they're going to take two
dollars and say please take a buck for
every dollar saved I'm gonna multiply it
by a hundred and make a donation to one
of the comments in the YouTube of which
charity or GoFundMe that you're
passionate about anyway couple things
the town wide sale starts at 9 A.M we'll
probably get there Abby what do we got
for that first address 8 30. that's
exactly right you want to get there
about 30 minutes early because it is an
early game and like there's people there
right now I like to find a little bit
more of a respectful tone like people
don't like you like sitting in their
yard as they're setting up we wouldn't
ask you yeah it is too late for you
anything that's past 30 minutes before
it starts is too late and the amount of
cynical cats that jump into the comments
in these episodes and like I see people
say oh this doesn't work and they always
have excuses me like oh what about the
gas prices what about shipping shipping
you charge for it like if you look
carefully some people are clever they'll
sell a 15 item for 99 cents but 15
shipping whereas other people who are
charging 15 free shipping it's the
psychology of selling gas you pay
there's cost in every business that
[__] job that you hate you usually
have transportation fees to to that you
have train costs you have gas fees let's
talk about what I'm looking for
for what I love stuffed animals
Nostalgia mugs video games pop culture
fictional characters Popeye Super Mario
Sonic the Hedgehog and Betty Boop and
trading cards there's one thing that
you're like at using
by an odds are in your favor what would
that be uh t-shirts that have like pop
culture like NASCAR Super Bowl Popeye
the Sailor Man like anything that's like
a dollar and under that's pop culture is
always great trucker hats hats have
exploded a lot of that Thrift Store
Brooklyn Hipster like I'm cool like let
me go pay 88 for an original Van Halen
t-shirt that [__] crushes what's the
energy you look for when you pull up to
a house I'm not overly worried about
energy when I'm garage selling I'm
worried about [__] executing there it
is Ranger Jersey trash talk I see a
ranger Jersey
good morning hi good morning
thirty dollars Jesus [__] Christ I
mean this woman thinks she's running a
[__] Boutique
have a great day
I mean that was [__] ripoff City I
thought the Rangers jersey was gonna be
a dollar she wanted [__]
30 bucks for a kids Henrik that's more
than it is in the [__] store King
Henry's [__] retired lady Jesus
Christ
we go let's see what happens here I like
the way this looks
Pokemon cards to you
[Music]
okay thank you
oh board games are sometimes good but
older stuff seeing any of that here how
much are these
would you offer yeah I genuinely don't
know
five dollars
thank you so much
silence is always a negotiation I'm
gonna count that as two dollars
negotiated for the charity so
and we are off some old Pokemon cards I
have no idea I'm actually not educated
enough on Pokemon to know if I did well
here or not but we're about to find out
all right we're off trash talk a nice
little stack of Pokemon cards for three
bucks we'll see in the comments that
this did this might be a decent one
One More by yourself I'm gonna come you
should come in with the camera oh yeah
for sure
oh boy
filming
no video games no
um oh let's go over here how are you
have the best day
hello my friend see how much they want
this on eBay how much that is yeah I
mean yeah check it out 1999 team
collectible trucks I think this is it
right the Yankees how much they were 15
bucks fifteen one five no you got the
wrong information
well no 15 for the Yankees
not for all oh just for one truck just
for one do you feel better now right he
was worried Nema you were worried right
how much you gonna sell it for 400 good
luck to you my friend I wish you well
with three how's that I'll let them know
300 everyone we'll let them know all
right brother
is that Pikachu really looks like
Pikachu
do you have any idea what that is
it is a Pokemon right how much is this
would you take a buck
fair enough
the dollars for charity thank you no
problem okay I just might have picked up
the Holy Grail sitting on this little
table handmade
Pokemon
this kind of unique stuff is pretty
amazing
[Music]
handmade rare vintage authentic 30 bucks
these are fun because you can't price
them they're handmade right so this is
just super unique like somebody just
falls in love with it with a good photo
and now you sell it for 30 bucks because
you can't price it Instagram what is
good I [__] picked up a gangster item
handmade Pikachu little [__] glass
okay
oh it's not a Pikachu what's everyone
saying I got it it's EB I got it it's EB
I'm sorry I apologize I'm [__] 47 I
was too old when they [__] hit hard I
guess that makes it 25 bucks all right
we're focused it's my next Target right
there all right let's do it
[Music]
since when
canteen it's cool 50 cents I'll have to
take that
let's see I Got a Boy Scouts canteen for
50 cents like I believe in this ship
like this feels at least 10 but I'll do
my homework I gotta go to Google we'll
search it anytime you're doing 50 cents
like you're in a [__] game oh there's
an estate sale get in here out
foreign
[Music]
I'm an entrepreneur nothing crazy have
the best day stay well all right this is
huge Nima mug life [__] mug life
and the one that I'm most I'm excited
about Starbucks mugs and guess which one
I got Indianapolis where the [__]
second V con was so I'm loving this and
we go to eBay
filter
sold
sort
those are OG's
jeez 23 dollars
77 cents exact same bug
good morning how are you
[Music]
how much are these sneakers
they're fresh would you do five on the
Nikes
how about six
steps
you got it thank you so much yeah
yeah okay so we just did that she wanted
10 she didn't get it she got seven 300
more dollars for charity which I like
but I'm not really sure I don't know
enough about Nikes
49.99 we'll see how that does
I asked hi hi are you Gary Vee I am hi
can I have a cup of lemonade
no thank you I'm trying to keep the
weight off
Daddy loves you love him we follow him
yeah
all right you keep the change okay
you're welcome
you got anything interesting
if you're a collector of music yeah the
music stuff is serious huh bro you got
Pokemon cards yeah you want to sell them
like
two hundred dollars
he's walking into a wiley vet he's
walking that boy's walking into a buzz
saw what do you do uh I actually do uh
for work right now I do a video and
photo I'm not gonna lie you're the
reason why I started doing it it's crazy
it's crazy right here
how much is it worth I looked it up it
said that exactly summer but did you
look it up in listed price or completed
sold price because what people get
confused on is they see what it's listed
for but that doesn't mean that it
actually sold for that okay what about
86 cents
just give me it for five dollars all
right so we got 81 off the board already
what's 520.
that's what I'm not doing what about
what about what about three three
dollars is huge money no
the biggest problem here is 81 dollars
in savings that's eight thousand dollars
to charity that I think this kid just
cost me let's do another one can you get
a 36 card I don't know it's only 36 for
this Charizard
this is E6 by the way this is how I
wrote 36 when I was a kid too and it
worked out for me so I have a good
feeling that this is going to work out
just nice for you okay make sure you
don't listen to the system okay do not
listen to the system this E6 brother is
the best thing I've seen all day can you
at least just give me 36 dollars for
that probably not
okay
if negotiations I lost
you got five dollars you won bro take
care so nice to meet you take care
I know Gabe's watching from what he's
probably up there he's watching
bye guys
here's the best part I'm convinced that
I paid too much for this card it was a
tough negotiator yeah Gabe is a beast we
need to hire game in the future
[Music]
what are you doing here I got the
million dollar motives
[Music]
how much are these stuffed animals what
if I took them off
one two three four five
you go eight
thank you so much have a wonderful day
stuffed animals that I'm excited about
thank you so much I'm gonna remember
this forever thank you okay I have great
[__] news I [__] crushed it I'm so
[__] hyped the neighborhood's
Gathering up what's up boys
all right I think we did extremely well
they want to say hi
boys
I love it what's up man what's your name
Ethan Ethan nice to meet you I'm Thiago
Thiago pleasure bro nice to meet you
hope you have the best weekend all right
2008 stuffed animals I mean with tag
2008 South par best part is two more
hundred dollars a charity because she
wanted ten she didn't get it she was
firm she was like no no I'm gonna stay
at 10 I'm like you're not staying at 10.
we're gonna at least get it down to
eight all right 2008 South
Park plush right you're not gonna
believe this these are really good 35
bucks this is just Kyle so Kyle's 35
bucks oh wait a minute there's a bigger
Kyle now here we go Kenny 60 bucks 80
bucks Kenny 70 bucks I've got the tags
70 bucks on Kenny 70 bucks on caddy
let's [__] go Cartman people buy 26
for Carmen this was the big score we
were looking for
foreign
this is why we lose that lady right
there has unlimited football jerseys in
her hand we missed them this is the
minutes that matter
good morning
I would like some lemonade this is your
first sale yes it is all right all right
how much
okay allow me to give you 20 is that
okay yeah we got some change no no you
keep the change oh my goodness what do
you say thank you you're welcome
thank you so much basically you've got
to always support the game
Nemo don't get hit by a car
[Music]
this is the Barbie [__] plan
how much is this
would you do five on this man
um I know she wanted seven I'm sorry
yeah just missing pieces okay thank you
thank you so much
Barbie air
another 200 a charity
she wanted seven Nema I heard she didn't
[__] get it we'll see what happens
with this Barbie Plane I'm really not
sure I could have looked it up just
being a little lazy this morning it
ended up being 32 bucks
how much are the hats
all right I'll give it some thought
thank you so much
I fit me at that I gotta do it
I'll take three of them okay have a
wonderful day take care of yourself just
put these down real quick a buck a pop
hats are hot right now
[Music]
that's the thing we did well with buck a
piece these new nice like especially
Yankees it's one of the best brands in
the world we'll look those up later did
pretty good three bucks saved 300 bucks
a charity what's this uh it feels like
it's like a mini Flea Market within the
[__] garage so let's see what's going
on here
foreign
[Music]
of course brother thank you fresh truck
nice 1969. but you're the Jets won the
Super Bowl the best year in the [__]
world you can definitely make this
lesson State sale let's go we're going
in a [__] house now [__]
in it
[Music]
I gotta learn Christmas
how much is this
dollar
Steelers
I'm in the dirt bro what's your name
telani nice to meet you brother thank
you bro nice to meet you
yeah bro I ain't playing it on TV I'm
living it yeah
nah man I'm real I'm in it pleasure to
meet you bro
Christmas is a huge category
it does
really well like some of this stuff is
monsters I just don't know it but again
this goes back to if I was doing it full
time I would just buy a bunch of it
learn donate what didn't work you know
you're not buying that scooter stock
well I'm gonna get it for 50 cents would
you take 50 cents for this I told you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you don't have any like older college
pennants
oh is that right but you're not going to
sell that right it's too nostalgically
important
okay how much do you want for those ten
dollars
let's do it
thank you
these are no joke Nema like we haven't
found ours yet but as you can see like
just Penn State from a buck 150 all
these are like 30 40 50 32 like
I would say the one we got is a is like
a 40. 25 to 40 dollar pennant
[Music]
that's my name
how much are these mugs right here a
dollar a piece would you do a dollar for
the two
no worries at all
there you go
I just liked her
I'm not sure I'm excited about this
purchase these might be crappy or
they're 19 and 16 a piece
[Music]
how much is the jacket five thousand
dollars that's it do you take cash cash
10 bucks respect and how about the video
games two bucks each
it's pretty cool you go 10 on this
11. respect thank you sir yes sir I
guess I'll find out later when I got
robbed that's right we'll see what the
Arbitrage is
[Music]
the Yankees kind of day look at this
vintage bad boy in that Medium hipster
style you can see half the [__]
office wearing this what's this guy this
guy's she's selling honey say the
garages [__] honey sales
honey I want to make money
oh I got something right here
what can you owe for [__] Ain't got it
they just be talking [__] Ain't Got It
how's your day going
good good are you taking a picture
yeah what's YouTube It's called
that's a station he watches all the time
you know YouTube yeah
yeah we're standing over there
he's very awkward right wait he's
introverted these coins are crazy
it's a good year
man yes I do nine months to make what's
your name first Lynn Lynn is here to
tell us everything okay Lynn
all right this was hand crocheted by me
okay isn't that beautiful it's gorgeous
talk to me about why you decided these
colors because
and my room was brown and green wait
what year did you
need how long did it take you nine
months like a baby
so what I'm going to do is after nobody
buys it I'm gonna go to a dealer and do
what sell it for how much whatever he
offers me what if somebody's gonna want
on YouTube I think so too late too late
YouTube wait somebody in YouTube just
offered five dollars did they yes you
interested no oh wait somebody in
YouTube just offered seven dollars what
are you crazy this is an eBay that's
right YouTube this is not eBay grow up a
little because people are gonna buy it
oh so you want to sell on YouTube
this is three dollars it doesn't look
like it no they like this there's a lot
of action on this 10 and final ten and
final ten dollars yep they want ten
dollars for this he says no what about a
Yankee blanket how much is this Yankee
blanket ten dollars no shot three bucks
I'm getting why three bucks for the
Yankee price
of three bucks no
no five five dollars
yeah thank you thank you so much here
hold this up with me this is this is
authentic it's a Yankee
take something from Mike what about this
how much what's the highest let me look
at YouTube Hold On
12 bucks more the blanket went up to 12.
I don't know how about 15. no but no no
I don't know all right you lucky person
you lucky person 12 bucks let's do it
handmade queen size I'm keeping the card
thank you very much thank you so much
exactly
43 years she's always right happy life
my man he knows take care of yourselves
bye-bye
I don't even know why the [__] I bought
this I've just loved her so much I had
to buy it but the Yankee thing's a
[__] beast you put this on an Etsy
for 100 vintage and you just [__]
kill it so that made it work that we had
a buyer she took nine months to make
this Nema like a baby so this was 35 and
we got it for what 12. that's 23 times
100 that's 2300 going to charity Nema
that Yankee [__] so when when you have
something vintage like that Yankees
blanket and there's really no comp for
it I'll look it up on eBay and all that
but that's the kind of thing at that
size that you can absolutely get 100
bucks for and so we got it for five
they wanted 10. they didn't get it
another 500 bucks a charity oh man
pretty pumped
wow all right everybody great day here
in Springfield New Jersey here at the
iconic Wine Library let's get you some
good wine while you're watching this
episode go to winelibrary.com trash talk
I'll put together 12 of my favorite
wines and I'll say code trash talk for
free shipping for a bunch of free
shipping I just made that up on the spot
I'm gonna make the team do that I picked
up this vintage Boy Scouts Cantina for
50 cents we'll see how much that is but
I'm predicting 5 to 25 on eBay for Etsy
I paid a dollar each for this Marvin the
Martian and Bugs Bunny mug life Express
this one is 18 this one's fifteen
dollars mug like [__] mug life
all right this one was potentially one
of the biggest scores of the day I paid
five dollars for this huge double-sided
New York Yankees blanket and I haven't
looked this up yet but this is the kind
of thing you put on Poshmark or mercari
or Facebook Marketplace not even on eBay
and sells for literally the Rangers
heavy 20 to 80 a pop I'm pretty pumped
about this a Majestic Authentic Yankees
beautiful gray little stainage here and
there I paid 10 for this this feels like
30 40 bucks and uh you know that hipster
New Yorker you know they're gonna rock
this [__] half my office wants this [__]
40 bucks I'm gonna say but we'll show
the Royal price if we have it all right
I bought these 10 pennants vintage got a
little glue on them so I'm gonna have to
put some work Michigan State Penn State
Georgia these are 40 years older more
Tennessee Auburn
Oregon State big shout out DJ illegally
Boston College Kansas State
Alabama we'll show you a series of uh
searches here of pennants that are like
it or the exact ones of this these are
like 30 to 80 bucks a piece we paid a
dollar ten a piece so these nine are
probably going to come in around 200 in
profit maybe even 300 maybe even 400
we're gonna have to look it up but major
score South Park plush are monsters
we've got Kenny and Carmen and we've got
multiple with tags we've got five of
them we paid 10 bucks there's only four
here I left one in the car five South
Parks we'll show you the results here
he's crushed these were monsters this is
a handmade Eevee Pokemon picked us up
for a dollar glass display again you go
Poshmark Pepsi Makari here more retro
more crappy more one-of-a-kind less eBay
though you should list it there as well
Facebook Marketplace fine I'm going 30
bucks on this I'm not partnering with
this EB for less than 30 and we paid one
to 29 come up three New Era hats in
decent shape Yankees USA devils and the
Brooklyn than that but I bet you these
are five to twenty they'll show them
here again three bucks you're looking at
30 bucks easy in my opinion but again
let the results speak here mug [__]
life Starbucks these are the big bangers
paid a dollar for this 27 or 22. you'll
show the edit mug life this LOL plane I
thought it was [__] Barbie I got
caught I'm a little rusty I admit but
we'll look this up this is what it's
worth we don't really we got to look
these up because we got to do sneakers
properly I'm not educated enough but I
know a lot of you are I think I paid
seven but this is what they're worth I
picked up this Steelers Christmas you
know stocking pretty upset with myself
but I paid 50 cents I'll get
10 bucks for it I picked up this Batman
3 PS4 game for a dollar it goes for 15
to 25. paid 12 bucks for this I'm not
even sure why but
took nine months to like
October 9. it took her nine months to
make
that's Jersey I'm not worried about it
Nemo we keep this fresh this [__]
Jersey we keep that sound this [__]
Priceless I ain't selling this I'm
living in it
[Music]
foreign